Elon Musk tweeted out this morning and
said that the deal with Twitter is on
hold he said Twitter deal temporarily on
hold pending details supporting
calculation that spam slash fake
accounts do indeed represent less than
five percent of users and he linked out
to a Reuters article that's about 10 to
12 days old at this point and estimated
that about five percent of the accounts
total users on Twitter are spam or Bots
Elon is basically saying I need to check
this out but I am still committed to the
acquisition right because immediately
people jumped on his back and they said
you were never going to do this anyways
this was all a publicity stunt you don't
actually intend to buy Twitter I think
there's a few different ways to look at
this and John I'm curious of your
opinion because ultimately in my opinion
I almost think this might be a
negotiating tactic right he came out and
he purchased Twitter or agreed to
acquire them for fifty four dollars a
share which was 44 billion dollar
valuation of the company the stock has
decreased or would be decreasing
tremendously if that if that agreement
wasn't in place given what we've seen in
the market right so stocks are not big
crypto's down big basically all assets
uh are down pretty big over the last few
weeks so I think that he might be
realizing hey I overpaid for this I was
super aggressive I really wanted the
asset it's probably not worth nearly
anything like that and now there's been
some turmoil right so they started to
fire Executives they've paused on hiring
a lot of people have started to quit
because of this and if they don't want
to work for Elon or want to go find jobs
elsewhere that's all cool with him right
he's saying like when I come in we're
going to change some stuff like if you
do not want to be part of that leave now
right go start searching for other
organizations which I think is fair to
both parties he's made his intentions
clear but ultimately now he's saying uh
in my opinion at least that this
acquisition might be too high he wants
to determine a few other things say spam
and Bot accounts are 10 of the platform
or 20 of the platform I've seen
personally external uh reports that
claim that it's maybe 10 or 15 so nearly
triple what Twitter is saying that it is
ultimately he has to do some due
diligence he didn't do it prior to the
acquisition it seems now he wants to
talk to Twitter more about it
interesting tactic tweet about it rather
than just go to the board directly but
that's how he rolls that's how he does
this so I think a little bit more is to
come here but I love this one quote that
Lex Friedman posted on Twitter that was
basically talking about the importance
of having someone or the potential
importance of having someone like Elon
Musk run Twitter and Lex said Elon Musk
is the only active engineer or scientist
in the list of top 50 Twitter accounts
music Sports comedy movies are awesome
but so is engineering and science I wish
there would be more of the latter to
inspire young minds who are curious
about engineering and Science and I
actually think that this speaks to a lot
of things that we've talked about on the
show which is that Elon Musk buying
Twitter is good because he's the person
that you want to be a role model for an
entire generation
and that has become a hot take for some
reason I don't know exactly why five
years ago it wasn't at all but now
people want to say that he was born rich
he had all these advantages in life
they're even claiming now major
Publications insinuating that he's a
racist for some reason uh but ultimately
a lot of these things have been
disproven anytime you actually look into
the facts of these situations it's not
true and I think what we've seen is that
Elon Musk is the person that we want to
inspire an entire generation right tick
tock is popped up right and you're being
blasted all these videos of people doing
dances and and doing all these things
that aren't necessarily going to drive
Innovation or create value for things in
this country and again entertainment is
a form of society that is important to
have but ultimately I think Elon Musk is
one of those individuals to Lex's point
that is now being put on that pedestal
and seen as that figurehead that he
should have been for a while because of
his engineering background because of
his Science Background because of all of
the the things that he is trying to
accomplish in this world and the
companies that he's building so I agree
that I think it's a good thing I think
think what what is to be determined is
ultimately what happens with Twitter but
hopefully this is a jump this is just a
bump in the road but I do find it
interesting that so many people already
taking Victory laps there's literally
accounts on Twitter big accounts I've
seen that are saying I I always told you
guys this was never going to happen this
was all publicity he never wanted to
acquire Twitter he's literally telling
you guys that he is still committed to
the acquisition he wants to check on
something right and maybe that drives
the price lower and they agree to
something else but the other important
thing to know is there's a billion
dollar breakup fee if this deal doesn't
go through right so if Elon Musk calls
it off maybe he can claim that they
misrepresented metrics and get some
money off or eliminate that completely
but if it's determined that he had bad
faith in one of these negotiations was
never intending to actually agree to a
deal there's a billion dollar fee he has
to pay I don't care if you got 200
billion 300 billion 400 billion 500
billion billion dollars a lot of money I
don't think he wants to waste that money
I don't think the investors that have
teamed up with him on this bid want him
to waste that money and I think my
assumption right just my opinion is that
this is hopefully a bump in the road
because the amount of reputational
damage and everything else that it would
happen for him to back out of this deal
now I think he doesn't want to deal with
and I truly do believe that he is doing
this for the good of Twitter right he
wants to see it become that Public
Square with free speech that it is
already it has always tried to be so I
think we'll see what uh happens over the
next few months right before the deal
closes but I wouldn't claim victory yet
I certainly don't think that he is just
going to back out of this deal uh
without putting up a fight I think that
he his intention is to do the deal at
what price that deal has done I don't
know what is your thoughts John I
wouldn't claim victory for either side
yet people that think that this deal
will go through or the people that think
that this deal will fall apart because
of Elon or Twitter and they're bored
right you have talked about you
mentioned Executives have left their
head of Revenue left right so people are
kind of realizing what's going to happen
in the future months uh their shares
sunk obviously but people are running
for liquidity so most of the market is
down anyways so it's not really directly
tied to this but yeah they went down 11
right people aren't as bullish as
possible I think the stock is sitting
anywhere between like 40 and 45 dollars
when he's saying he's going to take it
private at 54. look now people are
saying is it actually going to happen
I still believe he's trying to take it
private I don't think this was a money
play I think he honestly cares about
free speech um the Bots being 5 or 15 I
don't think matters as much as people
like really care about it like that is
if Twitter has 300 million users and
five percent you know it's 5 million
users on the platforms 15 is 15. so it's
a it's a large number but I don't think
it really matters I think cleaning up
the Bots as a whole is a big deal
um but the Bots have are more active
than other accounts and look to Lex's
Point as well elon's getting the
notoriety that he's probably deserved
for a very very long time we as a
society especially in the United States
put up a bunch of celebrities on
pedestals for sports and music and
entertainment and movies and things like
that but to be frank like they're adding
value to society but elon's value ad is
exponential compared to what a lot of
these people are doing and he should be
praised for that hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time